previously on TV sins oh come on
Moneyball let's make a deal come on you
people what do you mean you people
[Music]
our story is about a town a small town
and the people who live in the town not
to be confused with a dump a
medium-sized garbage dump and the trash
pandas who lived there although I have
concerns that would be far more
interesting to show also more CW
narration that reminds me I made a CW
show bingo card now instead of dreading
this paint-by-numbers teenage drama I
can pretend I win a prize and fool my
brain into creating happy fields train
station diner Cemetery police station
comic book shop excitement also look at
these innocent comic books as they
slowly bacon the Sun they're beautiful
fading from this world
what decent town would allow such a
crime and our story begins I guess with
what the blossom twins did this summer
pilot takes the framework for its season
long story line from I know what you did
last summer with 100% less Love Hewitt
and Michelle Gellar which makes it well
known a percent more butts in Dalton
doily who was leading Riverdale's Boy
Scout Troop on a bird-watching
expedition came upon Cheryl Cheryl was
the strangest bird he had ever seen an
instantly little man Doyle II knew that
this discovery would seal his fate as
the greatest peppy Boy Scout Riverdale
had ever known between the blossom clan
and Archie the show has more insane red
hair than a Ronald McDonald family
reunion I hope in those last moments she
suffered any hope of this being an
upbeat show based on the original Archie
comics has now fled
Durkin up down with pep understand the
show doesn't try to hide its twin peaks'
aspirations but casting Machin amick
feels a little over the top found your
porn as for us we were still talking
about the July 4th tragedy I'm not sure
why you wouldn't just call it the fourth
of July tragedy but I'm guessing it's
some pretentious book I'm listening do
they bring back Brittany Murphy I would
start composing these poems in my head
you don't even like reading poetry
they weren't poems they were song lyrics
then why wouldn't you just say you were
writing songs instead of poems aren't
you you guys go to Riverdale roll
commercials you're staring at our
pussycat ears which is rude but let me
break it and then down for you 11
minutes in and Riverdale gives us all we
need to know about Josie and the
Pussycats
they rude I tried every flavor of boy a
bad boy - Veronica is barely 16 and has
had every flavor a boy but orange Jesus
also besides being dressed like a
housewife she quotes Capote
while there and Woody Allen where did I
put that CW bingo card here it is
character backstory is perplexing
garbage dump Jack what are you doing
walking in this heat
nothing character right this is the
least subtle start to a teacher-student
romance on network television since miss
Jacobs and Pacey did the horizontal
tango on the Creek music you're the
music teacher can we talk about music of
course make an appointment during my
office hours my official wouldn't miss
Grundy need to make that appointment or
does each teacher here have a secretary
because I'm calling if that's the case I
can't very well have Hermione Lodge the
wife of Hiram Lodge on trial for fraud
and embezzlement balancing my books with
exposition and all but he could still
hire her to do anything else good knee
small town has lattes in high school
it's true eating saw a thing it's being
the gay best friend still I think Cheryl
would blossom a TV since at Spence I
said at the top of the elites pyramid
I'm in look Veronica is a perfectly fit
and fetching specimens but unless she
went to a school of giants there is less
than zero chance she was the school's
flier of course anyone's welcome to try
out but Betty's already got so much on
her plate right now
fat shaming follow me on Twitter and
I'll do the same my handle is that
Cheryl bombshell this is a real Twitter
handle with one tweet twelve thousand
five hundred followers and zero follow
back I'd say that's worth at least 125
cents
we heard fireworks who's playing
fireworks at 6:00 in the morning
clearly Archie was about to with miss
Grundy so we didn't say anything and
that makes you both terrible people
just in case Cheryl's social position
was in question she's managed to find a
throne from which she can sit and judge
the other mortals below her well you
haven't seen our Big Finish yet some
people see two faces some see a candle
there are no right answers just sticky
laptops Foam us being kissing hasn't
been taboo since 1994 taboo I'm me [ __ ]
destroy me well Cheryl looks for Betty's
dramatic side I'm looking for any adults
in this teenage drama hellhole I mean
besides the one having sex with a
student
Eddie and I come as a matching set you
want one you take us both I get that
Veronica's trying to shed her previous
pretentious skin and everything but she
just met Betty in the last 24 hours this
is a little too much when should be a
little creepy to Betty here
he couldn't find any other jersey number
except the one from a missing student
who is likely dead where's that CW
choping go guard don't support raid has
cold-hearted [ __ ] found it very
buddy Draper season 1 I don't think this
show understands the character of Betty
Draper very well what is that that is a
black bra and a sheer top which means
none of what you have to say for the
remainder of this scene will matter
can't I do this one thing just for me
sure but you actually said you wanted to
do cheerleading because the great on my
college applications seems like that
would be a pretty good excuse to get
Mommy Dearest on board what's that dad
is a desk owned by an idiot who can't
figure out that the chair goes on the
drawer side and the calendar shouldn't
be buried in a tray holding a candle in
porcupine booth Hermione probably has a
lot of questions about this sudden bag
of cash that her husband left her but
perhaps none more perplexing than that
stack of 50 s that say for a motion
picture use only that's pretty clear at
this point right he's a fraudulent
embezzler it's all over the news of my
knee that's it we don't talk anymore is
this the best time to salt Archie's
teenage driven identity crisis wounds
with your we don't talk anymore tears we
were this close to having a normal adult
figure in this show this clothes
whatever you decide be confident enough
in it you don't have to lie I'm taking a
sin off for this being the last work of
note on television for Luke Perry
alright peace sir you are and will
always be missed
I could totally see why Artie is so down
I mean having to walk into a room of his
peers with two beautiful women to the
side must be super tough I don't know
how these CW kids make it I really don't
can we in this post james franco world
be all things at once can we never say
post james franco world again he will
not believe who just propositioned me in
the bathroom give you a hint his name
may be moose but i describe a certain
appendage of his as horse lincoln
descriptions archie didn't we have a
deal
if these two are worried about subtlety
maybe don't bump it out in the back of
an untended car beneath the beacon of a
dome light late at night in the school
parking lot
these dread filled faces are silently
screaming get this over with then I'm
finally relating to something on this
show you miss New York it's been less
than a week but yes in the past few days
since school started there have been
football and cheerleading tryouts as
well as an assembly and formal dance the
real mystery of Riverdale is how the any
other
works definitely shouldn't do this
cliche where's Betty she spiraled and
flat shady [ __ ] yeah sure Cheryl is the
problem here
there's a saying about this type of
shortsightedness I can't see the shady
forest through the [ __ ] trees pretty
sure that's how it goes how was it I
mean it's not the Met Ball or anything
for Veronica to repeat her burn about
the dance not being the Met Ball only
means one thing
kissing Archie made her dumb and so it
wasn't one heart that broke that night
it was too considering Jason's dead body
is about to show up in the river we need
to add at least three more for his
family but most importantly my heart is
broken thinking about anyone on planet
earth watching this and making any sort
of relationship decisions based on what
they see absolutely this show please
don't make me look up how quickly a body
bloats beyond recognition in a river
please don't make me look up how likely
it is for eyeballs to be intact in a
dead body that's been in water for any
period of time by morning everyone would
be talking texting and posting about it
would you look at that entire town
contaminates crime scene and police
don't give it what's the final one I
needed for CW bingo Oh Mizer's are you
our sight for sore eyes Alou smithee's
you're quite good turning me on
I'm breakfast at tiffany's but this
place is strictly in cold blood
[Music]
nein no disrespect dad I don't want it I
don't want your life make sure those two
turtledoves come to my afterparty
I'm having an old friend
[Music]